alabama Governor Robert Bentley has
resigned following a scandal involving
an alleged affair with the top aide and
accusations of an elaborate cover-up his
resignation came just hours after state
lawmakers started impeachment hearings
against him Bentley pleaded guilty to
campaign violations they came to light
during the investigation prompted by his
alleged affair
Omar Villafranca is outside the State
Capitol in Montgomery
Omar good morning good morning last
Friday former Governor Robert Bentley
said he would not resign it that he did
nothing illegal what a difference a few
days makes this morning he now has a
criminal record and he is no longer in
office I have decided it is time for me
to step down as Alabama's governor
embroiled in scandal now former Governor
Robert Bentley resigned from office I've
not always made the right choices
Bentley stepped down after pleading
guilty to two misdemeanor violations of
campaign finance law he will not serve
any time behind bars
but has to pay thousands in fines
surrenders thousands in campaign funds
and will not be able to serve public
office again the charges are connected
to his alleged affair with a former top
staffer Rebecca Caldwell Mason both have
denied having an affair but a 130 page
report from the House committees special
counsel tells a different story
it included text messages provided by
former first lady Diane Bentley where
her husband professes his love for Mason
multiple times in 2014 Diane Bentley
even secretly recorded a conversation
between her husband and Mason
all this drama led to a battle with his
own Republican state lawmakers who
launched impeachment proceedings hours
after they started Bentley resigned
ending that process lieutenant governor
kib was sworn into office shortly after
Bentley stepped down the Ivy
administration will be open it will be
transparent and it will be honest kiv is
Alabama's second female governor as for
Bentley's plea agreement he has agreed
to not receive retirement or other
benefits as a governor and has to serve
100 hours of community service in his
capacity as a physician Charlie
Omar thanks